le brunch politique sud radio tour
d'horizon de petites phrases confidences
analyse louis morin décrypte l'actu
politique avec ceux qui la font
bonjour bienvenue dans le brunch
politique de sud radio notre invité
aujourd'hui marielle de sarnez vice
présidente du modem député européenne au
menu du brunch politique sécurité avec
les mesurant thierry terroristes après
les attentats il est question de mixité
sociale cette semaine un mode économie
avec la loi macron et la question des
seuils sociaux et puis les élections en
grèce avec la victoire probable du parti
d'extrême gauche syriza tout à l'heure
c'est marie-pierre de la gontrie
secrétaire nationale du parti socialiste
qui viendra débattre avec marielle de
sarnez le brunch politique sud radio
louis morin bonjour marielle de sarnez
bonjour merci d'être notre invité en
direct aujourd'hui sur sud radio alors
les mesures antiterroristes
tout d'abord le déploiement de dix mille
cinq cents militaires sur tout le
territoire national la création dans les
prochaines années deux mille quatre
cents emplois ministère de l'intérieur
l'équipement des policiers des gendarmes
réajuster un futur projet de loi sur le
renseignement est ce que vous êtes
satisfaite des mesures prises par le
gouvernement pour lutter contre le
terrorisme mariage les responsables
politiques qu'ils ont devant la
situation qui a été créée depuis une
quinzaine de jours maintenant
l'obligation d'assurer la sécurité de
nos concitoyens ça c'est la première des
obligations pour cela évidemment qu'il
faut renforcer les moyens de la police
qu'il faut renforcer les moyens de tout
ce qui est sécurité intérieure de nos
services de renseignement qu'il faut
renforcer les moyens sous le suivi de ce
qui se passe sur internet qui est quand
même le terrain de recrutement au fond
des jihadistes il faut se poser la
question de nos prisons qui sont des
prisons qui sont finalement qui était
écoles de crimes qu'ils sont maintenant
des écoles pour le terrorisme et donc il
faut se poser la question des prisons
dont tout chaque année le conseil
européen et tous les organismes
internationaux disent que ça ne va pas
en france mais il faudrait se poser
cette question raisonnablement en tous
les cas sauf que les premières
dispositions elles vont dans le bon sens
renforçons encore tout ça et puis ajoute
on il faut qu'on ait des dispositions au
plan européen
je suis évidemment particulièrement sont
si marielle de sarnez vous le dites les
organisations font le constat depuis des
années pourquoi nous n'avons pas agi
avant ça c'est france est un
on a chaque année le constat que dans
nos prisons par exemple ça ne va pas eh
bien on n'a jamais pris le temps et les
moyens font et la volonté politique de
se dire qu'ils se désinvestissement
conscient de changer oui mais de toute
façon cet argent il existe dans le
budget est peut-être qu'il faut aussi
gérer autrement peut-être qu'il faut
porter un certain nombre de réformes ça
vaut pour la france dans l'ensemble des
domaines moi je crois fondamentalement
qu'au fond depuis 30 ans
l'organisation politique de notre pays
un jour c'est la droite qui gagne
mécaniquement à la tous les
parlementaires un jour c'est la gauche
qui gagne mécaniquement la tous les
parlementaires n'est pas une bonne
organisation pour être efficace c'est à
dire que ça n'est pas une organisation
politique qui permette d'abord
l'expression du pluralisme qui est
absolument nécessaire au débat
démocratique et qui permette
l'efficacité de la décision politique
nous manquons d'une vision ferme et qui
s'appliquent sur le long terme dans
notre pays sur les grandes questions
cruciales que sont évidemment les
questions de sécurité évidemment les
questions d'école et évidemment les
questions économiques moyenne de 5 sur
les questions de sécurité il ya un
projet de loi donc un futur projet de
loi qui pourrait permettre entre autres
de cacher des micros dans des lieux
privés de faire davantage d' écoute ce
que vous y êtes favorable moi je suis
favorable à tout ce qui renforce la
sécurité dans le cadre de notre état de
droit nous sommes trois bertheux nous
sommes dans un état de droit et donc il
faut respecter des règles notamment
celle du pouvoir judiciaire c'est très
important tout ça se contrôle du pouvoir
judiciaire mais bien évidemment qu'il
faut pas être naïf et qu'il faut faire
preuve de fermeté et d'autorité mais les
jeux peuvent aller de pair ce qui a été
surprenant marielle de sarnez c'est que
la gauche qui a été hostile ces mesures
pendant des années et le fait de
gouverner vous rend vous vous renvoie au
principe de réalité c'est à dire qu'on
peut idéologiquement avoir des points de
vue ce qui est d'ailleurs un problème
parce que je trouve que les temps
devrait plus être à la question
idéologique on devrait essayer plutôt
d'avancer ensemble pour régler les
problèmes c'est ce que je vous disais il
ya deux minutes l'impro le creusement
que la gauche se confronte à cette
réalité là heureusement d'un point de
vue idéologique qui est un problème
d'ailleurs de cohérence avec christiane
taubira la présence de christiane
taubira au gouvernement promet veut pas
faire cette espèce de 2,2 de manière
dont la droite parle de christiane
taubira en permanence n'est pas la
mienne
moi j'ai gg je trouve que la question de
la justice est une question trop
importante pour la soumettre aux forces
on va dire partisane après il faut
évidemment justice et sécurité ça va
ensemble ça va de pair c'est le même
combat c'est le même combat mais la
liberté ça signifie aussi la
responsabilité la liberté c'est pas la
liberté de faire n'importe quoi et
n'importe comment la liberté qui
s'exerce sur internet et dieu sait si
j'y suis favorable
ben c'est une liberté qui peut passer ce
qui peut pas s'exprimer au détriment au
fond de ce qui est fondamental pour nous
ça a fait comme parlementaire européenne
j'ai fait il ya dix ans le premier
rapport sur la pédophilie sur internet
on m'avait expliqué à l'époque c'était
terrible que j'allais toucher à internet
que j'allais demander des choses aux
fournisseurs d'accès que j'allais porter
atteinte à la liberté moi je considère
que la liberté de s'arrêter là où celle
de mes enfants étaient menacés donc il
faut aussi prendre en compte nos
annonces faut-il mettre en place une
peine d'indignité nationale
écoutez franchement ça c'est typiquement
le genre de débat français dont la
france pourrait volontiers se passer
quelle est la question la question et
que on a des gens qui veulent partir
fallu jihad il faut les empêcher de
partir donc il faut les suivre les
empêcher de partir et on a des gens qui
ayant fait le jihad veulent rentrer chez
nous et se fondre dans la masse pour
aller commettre des attentats eh bien il
faut faire en sorte qu'il soit arrêté et
qui sera traduit en justice c'est ça la
question la peine d'indignité nationale
c'était pour l'école labo à la fin de la
guerre au fond les priver leurs droits
civiques la question c'est pas de priver
de leurs droits civiques les terroristes
ce pas suffisant c'est de les mettre en
prison et de les juger et d'empêcher
qu'ils nuisent donc on n'est pas du tout
dans le même propos donc c'est la
question des frontières extérieures de
l'union européenne qui doivent être
renforcés pour leur contrôle mais nous
ne sont pas encore à ce mais c'est une
question de moyens la vérité il faut
mettre des moyens supplémentaires moi je
crois que nous sommes dans des temps
difficiles de déstabilisation du monde
de menaces externes et internes qu'il
faut prendre un certain nombre de
décisions par exemple celle de dire il
faut des contrôles aux frontières pour
tout ce qui rentre et tous ceux qui
sortent de l'espace schengen il faut
peut-être en collaboration par exemple
avec la turquie qu'est vraiment la zone
d'accès à l'aciérie
remettre des visas provisoires montrent
l'espace schengen et la turquie la
turquie et l'espace schengen pour qu'on
sache exactement ce qui se passe dans
cette zone moi j'y suis allé pour voir
les camps de réfugiés syriens à la
frontière c'est très facile de rentrer
en syrie et bien c'est tout ça qu'il
faut faire et donc ce débat selon
l'indignité nationale est un débat qui
est hors de propos il ya quelque chose
qui existe c'est la déchéance de
nationalité que le conseil
constitutionnel a validé même tout
écoutez moi je me range plutôt de ce
côté là marielle de sarnez ya clairement
une défaillance de l'europe justement
sur ces questions là sur ces questions
de sécurité lorsqu'on voit par exemple
que les compagnies aériennes ne sont pas
tenus de communiquer entre elles et de
communiquer les compagnies aériennes
aujourd'hui elle communique dans leur
pays c'est à dire que ça se fait au plan
national il faut évidemment que ça se
fasse ou plan européen c'est le fameux
pnr passenger name recode qui sont tous
les renseignements sur les voyageurs
leur destination leur agence de voyages
c'est aussi leur carte de crédit c'est
aussi ce qu'il mange qu'ils vont prendre
comme repas dans l'avion donc c'est
beaucoup de données personnelles mais
elles doivent évidemment pouvoir exister
et pouvoir être transmises aux
renseignements pour autant que de besoin
et en même temps il faut évidemment que
tous ceux qui voyagent n'ai pas le
sentiment que toutes ces données
personnelles pour ceux qui n'ont
absolument rien à se reprocher c'est
quand même l'immense majorité de nos
concitoyens dont je suis pas sûr que son
fils est utilisé voilà de mauvaises fins
donc il faut que tout ça se fasse
évidemment ça doit se faire dans le
cadre d'un état de droit mais pourquoi
ça n'a pas encore été mise en place
parce que toute la question de rétention
des données personnelles n'a pas été
réglé les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement se sont pas mis d'accord
donc maintenant il faut que tout ça se
remette sur la table et il faut que tout
en respectant et données personnelles
évidemment des passagers il s'agit pas
de donner numéro de leur club d'être
signés tout le monde vous comprenez bien
la question il faut quand même
évidemment qu'on est ce qu'on appelle un
pnr européen talent y est la mise en
commun des données des passagers pour
que nos services de renseignement
puissent agir il faut renforcer ce qu'on
appelle europol pour renforcer ce qu'on
appelle eurojust et il faut une
harmonisation européenne par exemple on
a aujourd'hui c'est un pays qui
retiennent les passeports à ceux qui
veulent partir d'autres non justement un
dos en moi je propose qu'on harmonise
tout cela vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure sorti des djihadistes de
l'espace schengen interdire les
jihadistes français de revenir en france
est-ce que ce pourrait être également
une solution quand on écoute les
services de renseignement français c'est
pas pour eux la meilleure des solutions
eux ils préféreraient quand un
djihadiste rentre évidemment pouvoir
l'intercepter pouvoir le juger pouvoir
comprendre ce qui se passe est
évidemment qu'il soit condamné en tous
les cas on pourrait pas nous interdire
l'accès puis la belgique l'accepter si
vous voulez donc il ya vraiment besoin
d'une harmonisation le plus important
c'est de faire en sorte qu'il ne parte
pas là bas parce que là bas c'est
vraiment une école du terrorisme parce
qu'on parle des menaces intérieures chez
nous mais je veux pas oublier ce qui se
passe tous les jours en irak et tous les
jougs en tyrie encore treize jeunes
enfants qui ont été tués par des shows
parce qu'il avait regardé un match de
football tous les jours ce sont des
hommes et des femmes et des enfants qui
sont tués décapiter des femmes qui sont
violées c'est le bout de l'horreur et de
la barbarie alors voilà c'est tout cela
que nous avons en face de nous il ya
aussi la question du financement du
terrorisme faut-il lutter contre les
pays qui financent le terrorisme
on parle notamment de l'arabie saoudite
et du qatar oui bien sûr mais ce sont
des pays dans lesquels ils ont mené au
fond une politique une sorte de double
jeu en se disant si on est bien avec eux
et que certains d'entre nous certains
d'entre nous les financements peut-être
qu'il ne va pas nous arriver chez nous
ce qu'ils arrivent en irak ou en syrie
mais c'est évidemment un mauvais calcul
fait par le clic on vous dit de sortir
entre le rôle de l'arabie saoudite je
parle du qatar il peut y avoir certains
qui à un moment donné ont financé des
personnes ou des groupes en se disant au
fond c'est une manière de nous protéger
ça ne fonctionne pas comme ça vous
pouvez pas mettre le doigt dans cet
engrenage alors ils sont nés en emploi
vision qui luttent qui luttent en irak
contre des ch je leur en donne acte je
pense une clarification de ce point de
vue là serait une bonne chose laurent
fabius a formellement démenti cette
semaine mais louis caprioli ancien
sous-directeur de la lutte contre le
terrorisme à la dst affirme
effectivement que l'arabie saoudite et
le qatar continue de financer des
opérations terroristes un des
responsables le fond je crois pas que ça
soit au nom de l'état mais en se disant
au fond pour éviter qu'il se passe chez
nous ce qui se passe en irak et en syrie
essayons d'être bien entre guillemets
avec ces groupes c'est pas une bonne
politique de moyen et de long terme
louis morin le brunch politique sud
radio le brunch politique en direct avec
marielle de sarnez y at il des ghettos y
at il un apartheid aujourd'hui en france
marielle de sarnez il y à une france à
plusieurs vitesses tout le monde le voit
tout le monde le sait il y à des
citoyens français qui sont moins
citoyens que d'autres qui sont pas qui
est alors que nous devrions être dans un
principe d'égalité des chances la vérité
c'est que ça n'est pas comme ça que ça
se passe il ya des quartiers de
relégation
il ya des banlieues d'ailleurs pas
seulement des banlieues des endroits en
france où vous avez des taux de chômage
chez les jeunes qui atteignent presque
50% donc c'est évidemment quelque chose
qui dysfonctionnent profondément dans la
république française et qui est quand
même le résultat de 30 années de
politique dite de politique de la ville
où on a des gens de droite de gauche ou
de gauche et de droite qui au fond sont
très satisfaits de cette politique
depuis trente ans qui consiste à
déverser des milliards et au fond
derrière rien ne se passe on n'a pas
l'égalité des chances à l'école on n'a
pas l'égalité des chances pour l'emploi
et on a évidemment des conditions de
ségrégation en particulier dans les
questions du logement dans les questions
même de transport qui sont pas
acceptables dans une république
apartheid nicolas sarkozy s'est dit
consterné par l'utilisation de ce mot
par manuel valls
l'êtes vous aussi moi j'aurais pas
utiliser ce mot parce que j'aime bien
essayer on peut toujours se tromper
enfin des erreurs mais d'utiliser les
mots appropriés et je pense que c'est
bien de prendre les bons mots à
l'apartheid on l'a connu en afrique du
sud c'était délibéré c'était des lois
c'était des lois raciales et c'est tout
le monde le sait moi j'aurais pas
utiliser ce mot mais est ce qu'il y a un
problème en france
réponse est oui un problème alors j'ai
entendu qu'elle avoir un comité
interministériel de la ville on continue
comme depuis trente ans tous
gouvernements confondus
ça ne marchera pas plus et pas mieux on
déverse des milliards et on a toujours
les mêmes problématiques donc il faut
reprendre toutes ces questions à 0 à mon
avis au moins sur deux piliers il faut
agir 1 l'école
repenser l'école repenser la manière
dont on apprend les fondamentaux avant
le passage en 6ème repenser l'école au
collège il y à des jeunes des jeunes
adolescents des grands enfants pour
lesquels au fond le collège n'est pas
adapté jeudi à la pédagogie qui est
dispensé n'est pas adapté nous on avait
proposé avec françois bayrou ya
longtemps ce qu'on appelait le collège
hors les murs c'est à dire qu'on puisse
donner à ces jeunes là des points de
sens de repères d'ancrage heures dei à
l'école d'un côté un tiers des enfants
en tire des enfants qui rentrent en
sixième ne sommes ni argent ni
l'écrivain on sait car ce le bon chiffre
c'est 40 % 20 % ne maîtrise absolument
pas rien et 20% ne comprennent pas ne
comprennent pas le sens était qu'ils
peuvent ânonner ils peuvent lire et
comprennent pas le sens comment voulez
vous que ces 40% ne soit pas ensuite
complètement paumé au collège plus le
refus de toute autorité plus les
questions d'encadrement donc il faut
réapprendre à lire à écrire quand même
une république aujourd'hui et
spécialement la note elle devrait
pouvoir écrire et lire à tous ses
enfants elle ne le fait pas ça c'est une
faillite deuxièmement il faut repenser
l'école il ya en tous les cas le à la
neige c'est évident qu'ils aient un
manque d'autorité quand un prof rhum
dans sa classe ou croyais tous les
élèves se lèvent
quand un premier oui mais ça devrait ça
devrait quand des dès le premier jour de
la première rentrée quand un prof et
court à la vérité y consacrent dans
certains endroits 5 à 10 minutes à faire
cours le reste du temps qu'est ce qui
fait l'identité toi arrête ne te mets
pas comme ça te balance pas arrêté de
parler c'est que ça exactement qui se
passe pour le mieux parce que là je
passe sous silence ce qui peut se passer
alors dieu que nous léguer deuxième
chose il ya l'emploi l'économie donc ça
j'espère qu'on pourra venir que j'aurai
le temps d'y revenir on va y revenir
mais quelles solutions justement à
l'école tam ans pour redonner de
l'autorité il ya une déficience
également des parents oui mais on va pas
à tirer de tout régler que l'école fasse
déjà son boulot qu'elle apprenne à lire
et à écrire aux jeunes quand vous
maîtrisez la lecture quand vous
maîtrisez l'écriture quand vous savez
vous exprimer quand vous savez le sens
des mots eh bien vous avez une autonomie
qui vous permet de réfléchir de vous
épanouir d'avoir une prise de conscience
et deuxièmement quand vous êtes au
collège et que vous n'êtes pas adapté au
fond à la pédagogie très scolaire
quelquefois et quelquefois trop scolaire
eh bien il faut qu'on vous donne vos
chances de d'aller sous la
responsabilité du collège apprendre
autre chose d'être en apprentissage en
même temps qu'au collège et ça la france
ne sait pas le faire il faut qu'on le
fasse c'est une question vitale pour
l'épanouissement des enfants vous avez
des fameux cent cinquante mille jeunes
qui sortent chaque année du système
éducatif sans diplôme ça fait 20 ans
qu'on dit ça à satiété chaque année on
perd des places dans tous les
classements pisa et on est là on va dire
c'est qu'une question de moyens faut
remettre des profs non ça n'est pas
qu'une question de moyens il faut qu'on
repense au fond ce que nous devons à
notre jeunesse ça c'est la moindre des
choses que les enfants qui ont pas qui
par exemple rentrer en 6e au collège
sachent lire et écrire c'est pas mal de
sang à sursee des taux comme comment
peut-on faire pour avoir davantage de
mixité sociale gré à léo ce deuxième
point si vous voulez bien qu'ils aient
la question de l'emploi ainsi vous me le
permettez pas ce que je pense qu'on a
mis 90 milliards depuis 80 dans la
politique de la ville cette politique de
la ville elle ne marche pas alors on va
me dire oui mais si on n'avait pas mis
ses 90 milliards 6 cas ça serait pire je
ne sais pas moi je pense que par exemple
il faut un plan marshall de l'emploi
dans les banlieues il faut pourquoi pas
défiscaliser faire des zones franches
faire des zones franches dans les
banlieues pour que les entreprises
puissent s'y installer qu'elles puissent
embaucher par exemple des jeunes sans
payer de charges
jeanjean incertaine depuis dans un
certain nombre de quartiers y'a rien de
signifiant vous comprenez la politique
de la ville c'est une addition de
petites mesures actives damman ne marche
pas moi je crois que maintenant il faut
arrêter de vouloir tout faire donc il
faut se concentrer sur un ou deux
objectifs mettre le paquet sur ses
objectifs moi j'en vois deux à l'école
et pas comme on le fait depuis sept ans
de l'année différemment et de l'emploi
et donc vous voyez dans les banlieues
tout s'est tu il ya une énergie il y à
une créativité il ya une volonté
d'entreprendre
quand vous allez dans les banlieues par
les excès jeunes qui existent pourquoi
on la valorise pas marielle de sarnez
très rapidement mettre sous tutelle
certains quartiers c'est la poésie et la
proposition de malek boutih qui dénonce
du clientélisme qui empêcherait toute
évolution dans certaines villes mettre
sous tutelle je suis pas sûr je
reprendrai d'expression mais m un préfet
ou quelqu'un qui représente l'état qui
représente les services publics au fond
dans chacun des quartiers pour être à
disposition des habitants évidemment
régler les questions de sécurité mais
aussi donner le sentiment que l'état est
là qui n'est pas lointain que ces
banlieues ne sont pas relégués et que
l'état est présent et qu'il est présent
sur place ça c'est une bonne piste le
brunch politique sud radio
louis morin le brunch politique en
direct avec marielle de sarnez vice
présidente du modem près de 10 millions
d'électeurs élisent 300 députés
aujourd'hui en grèce le parti d'extrême
gauche syriza fait office de favori vous
espérez quel résultat de cette élection
marielle de sarnez d'abord moi
contrairement à d'autres leaders enfin
je suis pa li 2 o p assé je voulais pas
dire ça mais contrairement à certains ça
ce que certains leaders européens ont
dit en disant je me mêle de l'élection
je pense qu'il faut voter ceci cela moi
je pense exactement le contraire je
pense que c'est aux grecs de décider de
leur avenir
voilà alors on regarde les sondages à
mi-journée le solaire soit grosso modo
de combat est fini on s'aperçoit grosso
modo sida est en tête au fond moi je
connais bien la grèce est un pays
vraiment que j'aime j'aime beaucoup les
grecs je parle beaucoup avec eux ils
vont pas tant voté pour syriza que
compte la série t elle a été c'est ça
cette élection ils vont voter contre ce
qu'on appelle en grèce depuis 4 5 ans
l'austérité et c'est quoi c'est
effectivement le fait d'augmenter les
taxes tous les jours d'augmenter les
impôts tous les jours et de baisser les
salaires c'est à dire que si on regarde
ce qui a été fait depuis quatre cinq
années en grèce le contraire de ce qui
aurait dû être fait on aurait dû mener
et être à leurs côtés nous l'union
européenne pas seulement pour leur
prêter de l'argent mais pour les aider
dans les réformes structurelles pour
aider à créer un état et à le réformer
pour aider à créer un cadastre pour
aider sur la levée de l'impôt pour avoir
plus de justice et plus d'équité pour
imposer certains comme évidemment
l'église orthodoxe les armateurs les
oligarques entre guillemets comme on dit
quelque part ce revenir sur
l'indépendance de la grèce il fallait
être à leurs côtés de toute façon on
prête beaucoup d'argent 1 nous nous les
français les allemands les italiens tout
le monde les gars les européens
apprennent beaucoup d'argent donc je
pense que ils vont arriver en tête après
la question c'est de savoir est ce
qu'ils vont avoir la majorité absolue
151 sièges ou estimant avoir une
majorité relative qui les obligera à un
gouvernement d'union nationale ça on
verra ce soir dès les premiers sondages
de sortie des urnes
après ce qui est très intéressant c'est
de voir qu'ils ont un discours qui
évolue beaucoup depuis trois semaines
trois semaines il disait on va s'asseoir
sur la dette on la perd à pas il ya dix
jours et dix et on va renégocier on va
payer uniquement une partie de la dette
aujourd'hui il dit on va demander un
calendrier plus long et on va renégocier
notes dettes donc le principe de
réalisme terre que sa lenteur fera mais
vous allez voir ce qui va se passer
c'est que le principe de réalité
l'emportera ils ont besoin d'argent en
février ils ont besoin ils attendent
l'argent de l'union européenne vous
savez que par exemple si vous prenez la
principale région de grèce aujourd'hui
qu'est la région autour d'athènes ces
trois millions de grecs c'est un tiers
de la population
il ya une électricité gratuite pour un
certain nombre de familles ce que
tsipras sadique il qu'il promettait un
certain nombre de grecs qui est-ce qui
finance cette électricité c'est le
nombre sont les fonds européens s'il est
donc nous sommes partis liés et je
formule le voeu et je crois que le
principe de réalité prévaudra sans ça
vous voyez bien ce qui va se passer le
marché va jouer tout ça va s'effondrer
et ça sera une bonne chose pour personne
mais ils auront les grecs devront
conduire des réformes parce que il faut
aussi dire que c'est aussi tout ça
l'échec des gouvernements grecs depuis
le 20 ou 30 ans 1 s'est dit assez ces
grandes familles politiques grecs parce
que c'est toujours les mêmes un de père
en fils de droite comme de gauche un
socialiste comme démocrates n'ont pas
été à la bonne hauteur non plus de
gouvernement il faut le dire alexis
tsipras home c'est un modèle pour la
gauche française le leader de succès
visiblement belle pour jean luc
mélenchon mais pas que bon benoît hamon
cécile duflot en hongrie pour les amis
de jean luc mélenchon voit là puisque
j'ai vu que cécile duflot maintenant
vous voulez faire des choses avec jean
luc mélenchon
quand vous regardez le programme de type
race il ya le principe de réalité sur
l'euro il veut plus du tout aujourd'hui
quitté
la zone euro d'ailleurs angela merkel
qui disaient oui si jamais cette si
prince il faudra que la grèce quitté la
zone euro aujourd'hui elle dit mais pas
du tout on va pouvoir discuter de façon
apaisée de façon tranquille et ils vont
évidemment rester dans la zone euro donc
si précis va forcément être conduits à
évoluer sur la question européenne
mais nous avons partie lié nous avons
cette solidarité en même temps qui est
qui est quelque chose que moi je trouve
de positif mais si vous me dites est ce
que l'union européenne et les dirigeants
politiques ont bien fait les choses avec
la grèce depuis cinq ans je vous réponds
non et moi je ne dis pas depuis
aujourd'hui depuis longtemps j'étais
contre l'idée d'une troïka par exemple
c'est un mot mais atroce le mot tweet
c'est anonyme personne ne sait qu'il ya
qui décide quoi eh ben c'est pas une
manière d'aider nos amis parce qu'au
fond les grecs et nous la grèce la
france tous les états membres de l'union
européenne nous formons une même famille
moi je suis une européenne convaincue
nous défendons les mêmes valeurs nous
avons un projet de société commun et
donc nous avons aussi un devoir de
solidarité
marielle de sarnez vous l'avez dit
alexis tsipras renégocié la dette
concrètement l'union européenne serait
prête à octroyer une petite baisse de
taux et un étalement de la belle baisse
de taux avec ce que draghi a fait ça va
venir quasi-automatiquement manière
quasi automatique et en soins enfin sauf
que les titres ips l'ipra voudrait un
effacement de la dette tout au moins
partiel il faut savoir que la dette
c'est qu'est-ce qui la détient à la
dette qui a prêté l'argent c'est un
certain nombre de pays l'union
européenne et les pays vous croient
qu'ils sortent l'argent d'où de votre
compte si vous avez un peu d'argent en
banque et tourne donc ce sont les
français qui à hauteur de 50 milliards
ont prêté de l'argent aux grecs 49 je
crois que c'est 50 pour la france mais
je vous ai peut-être raison je
vérifierai dont je même le calcul sauf
615 euros par français voilà exactement
et donc vous voyez bien qu'à une
solidarité cette solidarité à une marche
dans les deux sens nous avons prêté de
l'argent en grec les grecs qui peuvent
simplement pas s'asseoir sur l'argent
que nous avons prêté parce que qu'est-ce
qui se passerait pour les français qui
ont cet argent dans leur compte en
banque
il se passerait une dépréciation
certaines est donc cette solidarité elle
doit fonctionner dans les deux sens moi
j'ai toujours pensé que la bce devait
prêter directement et non pas par des
intermédiaires pour faire glisser des
taux d'intérêt et donc c'est heureux que
les taux d'intérêt de la dette grecque
baisse c'est une bonne chose ensuite ils
auront besoin de conduire des réformes
structurelles ça c'est sûr et puis va
falloir qu'il retrouve au fond des le
baulois nca sens possible c'est à dire
que la grèce se disent au fond quelles
sont nos points forts et ils en ont des
points forts formidable et qui sont à
développer et donc je trouve que donner
plus de temps pour rembourser la dette
c'est aussi beau vous ne craignez pas
que ça renforce encore davantage les
eurosceptiques en france
ces menaces qui pèsent sur la tête non
je ne crois pas moi je crois quand vous
voyez le monde autour de nous on en a
parlé tout à l'heure quand vous voyez
les déstabilisations mais terrible
terrible qui se passe aujourd'hui en
syrie en irak au yémen quand vous voyez
ce qui se profile en libye qui est à nos
portes à nos frontières qu est ce qui se
passe au sahel ou dans certains pays
africains
qui peut penser que nos pays tout seul
pour est au fond faire bloc et faire
face à ces menaces
quand c'est impossible donc on a besoin
d'être ensemble on est plus fort
ensemble simplement il ya quelques
conditions pour s'être retrouvé au fond
l'amour des peuples c'est qu'elle
fonctionne de façon démocratique c'est
que les citoyens aient le sentiment que
les décisions européennes ils y
participent ils les prennent et ça ça
veut dire une chose qu'il faut que les
chefs d'état gouvernement arrête de
jouer avec tout ça arrête de dire à nous
on fait ce qu'on peut pour vous hein
mais vous savez à l'europe ils disent
c'est abominable parce que l'europe
c'est eux l'europe c'est nous l'europe
c'est personne d'autre que nous même
c'est pas une affaire de politique
étrangère donc il faut retrouver une
intimité avec l'europe et que l'europe
se consacre à l'essentiel elle sait trop
éparpillé l'europe elle doit se
consacrer à ce qui est fondamental
essentiel pour le reste elle doit les
services qu'on appelle d'un mot
compliqué le principe de subsidiarité
c'est à dire que tout ce qui peut être
fait au niveau d'une ville ou d'une
région où d'un état doit être fait à ce
niveau là au plus proche des citoyens et
l'europe elle doit s'occuper des grandes
choses qui nécessitent qu'on le fasse
ensemble de sarnez imaginons le scénario
du pire il n'y a pas de compromis
possible entre alexis tsipras et l'union
européenne est ce que la grèce pourrait
quitter la zone euro mais moi je ne
crois pas du tout je ne crois pas la
solution du pire parce que d'abord je
suis profondément européenne parce que
je crois que grosso modo en
responsabilité
on est obligé de penser à l'intérêt
général l'intérêt général c'est
évidemment que l'on reste ensemble
qu'est ce que vous voudriez que la grèce
sorte qu'elle se retrouve avec une
dépréciation de sa monnaie absolument
colossal avec une dette qui exploserait
je crois que ce sera un avenir pour les
qu'avec ça la vérité que non alors oui
il faut changer des politiques il faut
les améliorer
mais si on l'aimé moi jeune homme de
réformes structurelles dont vous venez
de parler mais vous savez fin février
ils attendent l'argent de l'union
européenne ils sont ils ont besoin de
cet argent pour payer leurs
fonctionnaires donc les deux seuls six
agents pour fonctionner les deux seuls
sites issus et soit de continuer à faire
des réformes structurelles qui vont dans
la direction de l'austérité soit quitter
ne sont pas d'accord avec vous du tout
c'est très important la phrase que vous
venez dire vous avez dit soit de
continuer des réformes structurelles qui
vont dans le sens de l'austérité jeu je
pense exactement le contraire de ça je
pense qu'on fait l'austérité quand on
n'a pas le courage de faire les réformes
structurelles
parce que c'est plus facile d'aller
diminuer les salaires d'augmenter les
taxes augmenter les impôts que de se
dire tiens je veux faire une réforme des
retraites et c'est ça qui est
l'aberration ça vaut pour la grèce ça
vaut aussi pour la france au passage ça
vaut pour d'autres pays pour les
gouvernants pour la troïka pour le fmi
c'est plus facile de dire où aller on va
ramener l'argent pour bercy en
augmentant l'impôt en augmentant les
taxes en baissant les salaires qu'en
faisant des réformes parce que pour
faire des réformes faut avoir du courage
pour avoir un consensus large faut avoir
la créativité faut être capable d'avoir
une vision faut avoir des perspectives
sur le long terme il faut
malheureusement ce que malheureusement
ce qui m'a l'eau souvent manque à nos
gouvernants et puis prendre le risque
également d'être impopulaire et de
perdre des élections partielles vous
savez enfin ce n'est pas forcément de
l'impopularité mais des élections
partielles marielle de sarnez je
voudrais vous en parlez 22 et 29 mars
prochain ce sont les élections
départementales nom qui ne sont pas
partiels des élections intermédiaires
excusez-moi élections intermédiaires
vous allez présenter combien de
candidats pour le modem où nous avons
des sortants qui sont conseillers
généraux jean n'est pas le genre n'est
plus le chiffre là aujourd'hui en tête
n'ont fait que je pense quelques
centaines puis bien sûr se
représenteront alors la configuration
est un peu différente puisque genève
lance leçons nationales aujourd'hui je
sais pas ce que veut dire une victoire
du front national aux élections
départementales ça voudrait dire que le
front national va gagner des
départements je ne le crois pas c'est
bien des présidences de départements je
ne le crois pas en tout cas ils vont
gagner beaucoup de lui il vaut ce qu'il
vaut avoir une progression dans leurs
élus qui sera au fond ce qui s'est
inscrit dans les municipales oui est ce
que la gauche va être en très mauvaise
posture nous verrons il va y avoir une
élection pour le coût partiel aux
législatives face à memphis latif
partiel dans le doubs qui va être très
intéressante à regarder
on va voir si le regain de popularité
pour françois hollande et manuel valls
se traduit par un regain un petit peu de
popularité pour le parti socialiste
est-ce que ça va suffire à la gauche ou
pas et ça va être ses grands équilibres
là qui vont être regardées pour les
élections départementales cette
législative partielle elle aura lieu
dimanche prochain et le lui février
pourquoi il n'y a pas de candidat modem
il n'y a pas de candidat modem parce que
quand il n'y a pas de bons candidats qui
sont capables de s'imposer qui sont
capables de rassembler large d'un il
vaut mieux de temps en temps ne pas ne
pas forcément aller à toutes les
élections c'est une élection qui va se
jouer autour de trois pôles
un bon candidat il ya toujours des
personnalités intéressantes mais après
faut des des candidats qu'ils puissent
faire 20 ou 25 ou 30% donc faut que des
candidats qui puisse rassembler large ou
qui puisse être soutenue par d'autres
formations ce cas de figure s'est pas
trouvé là nous avons toujours à
l'étranger à l'occasion dans d'autres
circonscriptions bien sûr vous apportera
un soutien au second tour de cette
législative partielle on va d'abord
attendre le premier tour c'est pas parce
qu'il ya quand même le risque que qui
est un candidat du front national au
second tour ça vous inquiète
c'est au fondant dans la logique de
cette montée du front national moi ce
que je constate c'est que le front
national monte depuis 30 ans dans ce
pays que la plupart des responsables
politiques qu'il soit à droite qui
souhaite à gauche ils y ont une part de
responsabilité importante que le système
institutionnel politique il ya une très
grande part de responsabilité et c'est
pourquoi avec françois bayrou nous
demandons un changement de ses
institutions depuis longtemps on ne peut
pas vivre dans un pays où au fond vous
avez à l'assemblée nationale 90 % des
parlementaires qui représentent que 40 %
des français ça ne peut pas fonctionner
comme ça on a besoin de pluralisme on
est plus intelligent à plusieurs donc si
le fn un candidat au second tour vous
n'appellerait pas forcément à voter
contre ce candidat nous soutenons le
camp dial l'ump au premier tour donc à
une logique est ce qu'on soutienne le
même candidat au deuxième le brunch
politique sud radio louis morin le
brunch politique en direct avec marielle
de sarnez et marie pierre de la gontrie
secrétaire nationale du parti socialiste
et vice-présidente de la région
ile-de-france bonjour marie pierre de la
gontrie l'audio alors depuis tout à
l'heure on évoque un certain nombre de
sujets avec marielle de sarnez on va
revenir sur la loi macron demain
l'assemblée nationale le projet de loi
macron le travail du dimanche
la déréglementation d'un certain nombre
de professions vous vous êtes favorable
à la loi macron marie pierre de la
gontrie j'imagine marielle de sarnez en
revanche ce n'est pas le cas
ont été débattus vous l'avez évoqué
peut-être en utilisant un terme qui
n'est pas totalement approprié tu peux
me permettre n'est pas vraiment le
travail le dimanche mais l'ouverture de
certains magasins les noces et est vrai
que lorsqu'on est en ile-de-france
lorsqu'on est à paris c'est un sujet sur
lequel on est très attentif parce que
permettre à certains d'accéder à
l'emploi nuit trois fois oui permettre à
certains qui ne veut pas faire leurs
courses en semaine oui trois fois oui
mais attention attention à ce que notre
mode de vie ne soit pas totalement
dérégulé à que les personnes déjà en
difficulté comme les femmes par rapport
à l'emploi ne se trouve pas dans une
situation où l ont plus d'autre choix
que de travailler le dimanche ou le soir
jusqu'à les nuits puisque vous savez que
c'est une disposition jumelles donc mais
un très bon travail qui est échue en
collection vous n'avez vu maintenant
derrière qui a permis d'améliorer un
certain nombre de dispositions qui
posait problème et puis va livrer le
travail en temps mais tenait à cette
question de l'ouverture des magasins le
dimanche est un sujet intéressant mais
il ya aussi la question du nombre de
dimanches marielle de sarnez
5,7 ou douze dimanches par an j'ai dit
bonjour d'abord à marie pierre de la
gontrie et qui est à l'enjeu non moi je
suis tout à fait favorable à l'ouverture
des commerces le dimanche dans certaines
zones et parce qu'il faut pas faire
croire que ce serait par exemple surtout
paris
paris tout fonds capital international
mondial bah c'est important que cette
ville vive évidemment ça ne peut se
faire que sur la base du volontariat
c'est à dire que ceux ou celles qui
peuvent et qui ont envie de travailler
le dimanche le dimanche soir ça ne peut
vraiment se faire que sur cette base
c'est extrêmement important mais qu'il y
ait dans quelques zones de paris et
surtout pas tout paris la possibilité
effectivement de consommer de rencontres
et de d'être dans des gares où sa vie
parce que les commerces sont ouverts
d'être pourquoi pas à côté des grands
magasins se les grands boulevards parce
que là aussi les touristes peuvent y
aller plutôt que d'aller à londres -
tout ça franchement ça me semble aller
dans la bonne direction mais moi ce que
je trouve absolument incroyable c'est
que nous débattons de cette question de
l'ouverture des commerces le dimanche
depuis des semaines et des semaines et
des semaines et des semaines et qu'au
fond le bon sens devrait être de dire
will bien sûr dans certaines zones d'une
capitale comme paris ça semble
évidemment aller exactement là où il ya
aussi la question de la déréglementation
d'un certain nombre de professions marie
pierre de la gontrie bruno le maire
craint la disparition par exemple des
offices notariaux dans les plus petites
communes
je suis avocat
le problème de la concentration d'un
certain nombre de professions dont on
pense par choix
efficaces dans d'autres donc sur cet
acte là je pense que l'idée est très
intéressante après il faut effectivement
bien sûr que cela n'ait pas d'effets
retour qui soit totalement négatif qui
ne se rapproche pas de l'objectif
ensuite il faut savoir que cathy v2 de
faire en sorte qu'ils aient une
installation faite de réguler elle est
aussi doublée d'une idée sur la
tarification
alors oui je pense qu'il ya un mélange
qui est à dire qu'il n'est question de
transparence tout le monde pense que
comme ça les notaires qui est cher
croyant d'ailleurs que les montants
qu'ils prélèvent vont directement dans
la poche qui n'est pas le cas vous savez
de la même manière aucun blocage et de
prouver qu on pense que les avocats
fischer qui n'est pas toujours fou
d'ailleurs donc l'idée d'avoir une
transparence sur les paris l'idée de
faire en sorte qu'il y ait zéro de
france pour manque de professionnels qui
put y avoir un conseil comment bien un
regard général au fond et de
l'aménagement du territoire c'est à dire
comment fait-on tout et partout en
france qui lui est y avoir un accès à
des notaires des avocats qui n'étaient
pas concentrés simplement dans les
villes urbaines voix ip revel passé
c'est un vrai sujet
magna de sarnez sur la déréglementation
des professions réglementées
écoutez je pense qu'il faut écouter
aussi les notaires parce qu'au fond ils
connaissent leur boulot et c'est eux qui
s'y colle j'ai pas le sentiment qu'il
trouve que cette réforme va dans le bon
sens donc moi par principe j'aime bien
que quand on conduit des réformes on
puisse les conduire avec ceux qui vont
les mettre en application est ce qu'il
faut améliorer des choses sûrement est
ce qu'on peut en décider ensemble avec
eux je pense que ce serait mieux vous
pensez qu'il aura une majorité actuelle
pour la faire adopter cette loi on va
coûter oui je pense que oui moi je pense
que c'est une manche devant un c'est pas
une loi d hier hollande a dit lui-même
c'est pas la loi du siècle donc faut pas
non plus
question de l'économie de l'emploi en
france ce serait absolument de faux
c'est une loi qui va faire quelques
ajustements qui sur 7 un sujet vont dans
le bon sens mais c'est un peu aussi un
inventaire à la prévert il ya un peu de
peu de tout dans cette loi il n'y a pas
il n'y a pas vraiment un message ou une
vision globale facilement perceptible
par nos concitoyens
-
le métier terme ans alors ce passionné
avec les verts parce qu en particulier
qu'on a qualifié d' un peu
un accord avec tata steel a décrypté
mais savez comme vocation de faire
pomper un papa nom de berri il a tu dois
je pense que c'est positif ensuite que
je vois c'est que le travail
parlementaire s'est bien passé on a eu
de l'écho dernier qui a qui a été à
l'écouté ça va continuer cette semaine
je trouve que c'est plutôt bien même si
je suis d'accord avec marielle de sarnez
sur lequel on aurait pu rêver d'une
concertation qu'il approfondit mais
c'est toujours pour la nouvelle année
comme moi on écrire des textes dont ceux
qui se mettent en mode rapidement et en
temps de la concertation donc il fait
toujours été trouvé le juste milieu au
fond de débat parlementaire le permet
donc
marie pierre de la gontrie il ne reste
plus beaucoup de temps je voudrais juste
revenir avec vous sur la politique de la
ville tout à l'heure marielle de sarnez
dénoncé l'utilisation de 90 milliards
d'euros au cours des 20 dernières années
dans la politique de la ville utilisé à
mauvais escient faites-vous le même
constat
de la ville et encore une fois ce n'est
pas parce que nous constatons que est
encore énormément de choses à faire
qu'il ya effectivement un grand nombre
de quartiers qui sont en difficulté que
pour autant il faut prétendre que ce qui
a été fait jusqu'à présent n'a pas été
utilisé la france n'est pas que je suis
à la courneuve la cour note que c'était
des îles et qui n'est que juste à côté
par les connaissez certainement et là
aussi on voit énormément de choses moi
je vois lorsque la région de france à a
développé des lignes de tramway qui sont
que tout le territoire qui n'était pas
raccordé par les crampes en commun le
fait aujourd'hui donc attention
attention à ne pas confondre débat du
moment qui est juste est absolument
obligatoire et les amène à remettre en
cause et à réfléchir tous à chaque
classe nous sommes à nos politiques et
ne pas considérer que rien n'a été fait
défaut et c'est très très crypte
considérer la
maladie sur la politique de la ville ce
n'est pas de l'argent dépensé à mauvais
escient je n'ai jamais évidemment
prononcé cette phrase simplement je
crois qu'on est obligé tous responsables
politiques la temps de regarder la
situation en face ça fait trente années
qu'on a ce qu'on appelle une politique
de la ville que grosso modo cette
politique de la ville est la même on va
dire à peu près quelles que soient les
gouvernants depuis trente ans de droite
ou de gauche le résultat des courses
c'est que ça ne va pas c'est qu'il y a
des problèmes qui sont là encore plus
important est encore plus lourd qu'il y
a 20 ans ou 30 ans et donc je dis il
faut peut-être se poser la question de
ce qui doit être fait moi je considère
qu'il y à deux axes sur lesquels il faut
mettre le paquet absolument qui est un
la question de l'école et de l'éducation
de la formation de la question de
l'emploi parce qu'ils vont créer c'est
vital de l'emploi dans les banlieues et
dans toutes ses zones de relégation en
france et je pense que l'argent qu'on
doit avoir à disposition la créativité
l'inventivité les réformes doivent aller
sur ces deux questions merci michael
dawson